okay all right welcome back everyone so
this is the last lecture of the fall
quarter 564 class and then I'm how many
of you are taking 565 next quarter or
any of you not taking 565 next quarter
okay so I'll see most of you in the next
quarter which is great let's see a
couple of things okay you're gonna get
an email for online course evaluations
next week so please fill those out give
some indication of what worked in the
class what didn't you know if you learn
something or not so these are really
useful for me and also for the
department to tell whether or not I
should like be teaching here or not okay
about the exam the exam is due today at
5:00 I've already received exams from
about ten of you so that's great I
wanted to point out one little thing so
in the course notes so how many of you
have started the exam have any of you
not started yet
it's okay okay good someone to talk
about it a little bit because all of you
have probably seen it sorry I didn't
want to open the exam I won't open the
lecture notes so there was a lecture
where I talked about finite difference
derivatives I think it was this one and
essentially I derived kind of the error
you know the minimum error for like a
Delta X for a finite difference
derivative scheme so some of you
probably have seen this the first part
of this is all fine but I made some
major mistakes when I was doing the
actual evaluation of the Delta X so I
just want you all to be aware that if
you're following my notes you should
actually like really do this problem
again yourself because there might be
some minor errors in the details of my
derivation but the idea is basically
there so I just wanted to tell you
because I feel like it would be kind of
unfair to have a wrong solution to an
exam problem in my notes and not tell
you about it uh can anyone guess what
this plot is of any ideas okay yeah so
what does PCA stand for I heard you say
it I think you know anyone else okay
well there's PCA stand for principal
component analysis so here this is
actually kind of an amazing dataset
really phenomenal this is the amount of
money brought in by each of the largest
13,000 insurance carriers in the US
along features defined by what kind of
policies they issue so this is the kind
of so this is just a teaser for some of
the kinds of things will do next quarter
next quarter we're gonna focus on
partial differential equations but I'm
also going to tell you a lot about data
analysis so how do you essentially take
very very high dimensional data
I think this insurance data we had 64
gigabytes of policy information over 200
million insurance policies over 20 years
but you can distill it down to these
very simple actionable interpretable
results where if you're over here on the
left with these red large circles that's
good you're making boatloads of money
and if you're over here you're not
making hardly any money at all okay so
this is like a very very simple
distillation you know so I want to teach
you about data skills and I want to
train you all to be essentially data
consultants because that's what you're
going to be for your advisors in a
number of key points in your career okay
let's see so today we're going to
revisit this double gyre example okay so
this double gyre is an example that we
derived at the very end of class last
time
so we have this stream function Phi of X
and y is given by sine PI X sine PI Y so
it's periodic in x and y and you can
define this vector field V by taking the
partial derivative of the stream
function with respect to Y and X just
like we did for potential flow so stream
functions and potential functions are
pretty similar in how you use them and
so we derived this vector field V given
by PI times sine PI X cos PI Y and the y
component is minus PI cos PI X sine PI Y
okay so the first thing we're going to
do is plot this in P plane and get a
feeling for what this vector field
actually look like looks like and then
I'm going to add in a time varying
spatial frequency for the X component so
I'm gonna have this system start to move
in time and we're gonna do all kinds of
interesting analyses we're gonna look at
where particles go we're gonna look at
where this flow is sensitive to initial
conditions so if you were gonna drop oil
there are some places that would be much
better to drop it than others okay or if
you want to track an oil spill or a
contaminant release in this kind of a
vector field you know we're gonna start
to get to some of those ideas today any
questions about this double gyre before
we kind of jump into some MATLAB code
the one one point definitely looks like
a saddle point exactly so if you looked
at what was happening above this I think
it would look like a fallow point so
there's a fixed point right here where
if you're if you're exactly at that
point I believe that your velocity field
is zero yeah so all of the corners are
every integer location on the integer
grid is a fixed point of this vector
field and some of them are saddles in
fact I think all of them are shuttles
yeah yeah so one half one half might
what is that yeah so that would also be
a fixed twenty right so sine of PI
halves
sorry cosa PI halves would be zero yeah
and that's the center so that's a good
point so what you could do here if you
wanted to maybe someday this will be on
one of my exams is find all of the six
points for this double gyre system and
then characterize them into saddles and
centers
okay so let's actually code this up so
I've already started I have P playing
open and let's see if I can do this okay
so in P plane I have this vector field
defined over all of X&Y the X component
is PI sine PI X cos PI Y and the Y
component is minus PI Coast PI X sine PI
Y and we're deriving we're going to show
this on the interval from 0 to 2 and 0
to 1 in the Y direction and I really
hope it looks like what I think it
should and it does okay so if I click on
this you can see that the closed curves
really are circles this has some
numerical and accuracy so it's losing
energy but that's just because it's
numerically not integrating it very well
okay and so that's the basic idea of
this vector field okay so I have a
vector field defined on all of space and
I've kind of zoomed in to the spatial
spatial region from 0 to 2 0 to 1 and
now what I can do is I can use that
vector field as the right-hand side for
a set of ordinary differential equations
ok so I let me write this down I have I
have this vector field which has a you
know two components V 1 and V 2 and V 1
and V 2 are both functions of all of
space x and y and so I could say that X
dot equals V 1 of X Y and Y dot equals V
2 of XY ok and this is where you would
find the fixed points are saddles and
centers and you would look at the
stability and do all the stuff that we
did in the first half of the class so
does this make sense how we can take a
vector field and we can then integrate
particles through that vector field ok
we could do it analytically if this was
a simple system we might be able to
actually you know if this was a simple V
vector field then we might be able to
find a solution by hand about what we're
probably gonna have to do is use
something like OD e45 to get a numerical
solution to this vector field and that's
exactly what p plane is doing you define
a vector field and then it essentially
integrates particles using OD e45 to see
what their trajectory would look like ok
all right good so now what we're going
to do is we're going to change this
vector field a little bit so how am I
going to do this
okay let's make sure I can actually do
this okay so I'm gonna change my vector
field a little bit to make it time
varying and this is gonna be pretty like
a pretty simple change but it's gonna
actually make a huge difference so
before my stream function was Sai of x
and y equals what was it sine PI X sine
PI Y yeah sorry side PI X sine PI Y and
then when I took the partials I got sine
Coast cosine so what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to make this all I'm going
to change is I'm going to add a
frequency the time a time varying
frequency so my new PI is going to be
sine of pi f of T X sine PI Y okay and
this F is actually let me see this is
actually going to be a function of both
X and T okay my frequency is going to
depend on X and T and so my and let's
think about what this means
so if I have a time varying frequency X
then that means that the spatial
oscillation frequency might be speeding
up or it might be slowing down all right
and having this F 2 as a function of X
means that essentially what I can get is
instead of equal and opposite vortices
what I'm going to have instead
are unequal and opposite vortices so I'm
going to have one larger one that's
moving faster and maybe one smaller one
that's moving slower so that's what this
f of X and T is going to allow me to do
is have the system kind of oscillate
back and forth between having one really
big vortex on the right and then one
really big vortex on the left and
they're going to go back and forth so
this f of X and T is given by ax squared
plus BX where a is a function of T so a
of T is some epsilon times sine Omega T
okay you can kind of work through why
this does the things we want it to do
later the basic idea is that this
frequency has a couple of zeros and
those zeros change as a and B change B
is 1 minus 2a okay I didn't come up with
this some like ocean engineers came up
with this function that does what they
want it to do but you can still do the
same thing you can say that v1 and v2
equals and I think it's partial psy
partial Y and minus partial by partial X
and when you take partial with respect
to this X now you not only have a coast
PI f of X times X but you also have an F
prime of X ok that's basically all there
is so I'm cooking up this new stream
function and the stream function has an
x frequency a spatial frequency that
varies both in space and in time okay so
I'm going to code this up and we're
going to see what this does to our
double gyre vector fields
any questions about that stream function
before before I move on I mean I didn't
tell you much about it I kind of just
made it up
or wrote it down okay so I suppose we
could have actually plotted this in P
plane we could have picked a value of a
and B and we could have plotted the
instantaneous vector field in P plane
but I think what I'm going to do instead
is to actually just solve the whole
problem so so here I'm defining a
right-hand side vector field remember an
OD 45 to integrate particles you need a
right-hand side so I need to define
these functions v1 and v2 okay and so
this double gyre vector field is time
varying but the function of time it's a
function of the spatial location which
I'm calling Y this is a vector of the
X&Y positions and it's a function of
these parameters a epsilon and Omega
which I'm going to lock into place
because these have been kind of defined
already by the geoscientists like they
know what any epsilon and Omega should
be for ocean systems okay now remember
when we did the Lorentz equation we did
a big for loop for you know for I equals
1 to whatever for J equals 1 to whatever
for K equals 1 or whatever and it sucked
it was super slow so instead we decided
to have a vector valued state where this
Y in is actually a huge array of the X
initial condition over all of the grid
points I define and the second component
is another huge two-dimensional array of
the Y initial conditions over all of the
initial conditions I'm defining okay so
this yn is really a 3 dimensional array
it's got a V 1 and a V 2 component
defined for an entire 2-d array of grid
points so so on my entire spatial domain
let's say I have a hundred by 50 point
so I have 5000 grid points to find okay
then this is going to be sized to buy a
hundred by fifty okay and it's going to
be the X&Y positions for all of these
five thousand points okay so this for
example you know if I define this huge
grid of particles this yn is going to
keep track of the X&Y positions of all
of them okay so now I'm defining my
actual velocity field U and V here I
called it V 1 and V 2 but here you can
call it U and V it doesn't matter as a
bunch of zeros and then I'm gonna
populate them with values based on my
stream function okay so I have this a
value which is epsilon sine Omega T B
equals 1 minus 2 a I can define f and
the derivative of F with respect to X
this is my time varying spatially
varying frequency and then I can define
my U and V velocity components by taking
the partial derivative of my stream
function ok so this is exactly what we
did for the simple double dryer that was
stationary but now we've done it for a
time varying frequency F in the in the X
component so you can kind of work out I
should probably give you a reference to
the paper where this vector field is
defined but it's pretty straight forward
from the stream function that I wrote
down to get this U and V you just take
partial of Y with respect to Y and
partial açaí with respect to X and you
get these two components ok I don't want
to spend too long on this because the
specific vector field I'm choosing
doesn't really matter that much
some smart scientists decided that this
vector field modeled a physical system
they care about okay there's an ocean
model and there's a vector field that
models the ocean in a particular way and
what this code does is it returns the U
and V velocity components for every
single particle in my a grid defined by
Y in
okay so I had this huge grid of
particles defined by Y in and the output
is a huge grid of U and V velocities for
each of those particles okay and then I
stack it into a three dimensional array
okay let me just double check and see if
there's if anyone wants to talk about
this before we move on to actually
integrating the vector field are there
the basic idea make sense we have a
vector field we're looking at particles
in the vector field and I can define the
velocity at each of those particle
locations by taking the stream function
derivatives okay okay so this is where
it gets fun so here I'm going to make a
function called integrate double gyre
temp so we're gonna integrate this thing
now okay so first what we're going to do
is I'm going to essentially define a big
grid of initial particles and I'm going
to ask what is the velocity at each of
those particles I'm going to plot it
okay make sense so let's say a equals
0.1 x equals 0.25 and Omega equals to PI
over 10 these are the values from the
model okay these are the values that
somebody defined as good values for the
model and so part one we're going to
initialize a grid of particles and
integrate through the vector field okay
okay so for this grid of particles I get
to decide what is my Delta X and Delta Y
like how many particles do I have what
is the resolution that I'm going to
start looking at this system and in real
life I would use something pretty small
like 0.01 or 0.001 but to make this fast
and kind of reasonable I'm gonna choose
kind of a coarse DX just so we can see
things move quickly so 0.025 this is a
coarse Delta X and now I'm going to
define a vector of x coordinates and a
vector of Y coordinates and then we're
going to use those to create this mesh
grid array of initial conditions just
like we did for the Lorenz system okay
so my X Veck is 0 increments of DX to 2
and my Y vecas C row in increments of DX
to 1 and if you wanted a separate dy you
could have a separate dy but I just want
it to be uniform spacing and then I'm
going to say X naught Y naught equals
mesh grid of X BEC and Y Veck this is my
grid of particles and at this point I
probably should be able to actually plot
them so I could plot X naught and y
knots and let's plot them as red dots
kind of large red dots hopefully this
works good that's my grid of particles
okay all of those red dots are my grid
of particles over this domain okay so
how many of you remember this mesh grid
commands anyone like me to talk about it
a little bit more yeah okay right so I
just tell them you know what is the
range of X's all the X values what's the
range of Y's all the Y values and then
mesh grid populates that 2d array from
all combinations of those X's
wise so what do you think the sizes of X
naught and y naught should be length of
x times the length of Y right so let's
try that so if we say length x Veck is
81 which is I think 2 divided by 0.025
plus +1 ok length Y VEX 41 and then size
of X naught is 41 by 81 which is a
little bit weird so this is actually not
what I thought it would be I thought
this would be 81 by 41 right because my
X is bigger than my Y so I thought it
would be 81 by 41 but in MATLAB it's 41
by 81 that's weird
so I just take the transpose okay okay
good and now remember I had that
variable Y in in my vector field here
I'm just gonna call it Y I see all of my
initial conditions the first component
of initial conditions is just X naught
Prime the second component of my initial
conditions is y naught prime okay so now
this initial condition array has three
components it has the X component and
the y component for the whole 2d array
of particles okay so the size of this if
I said size of Y I see it would be size
2 by 81 by 41 right I've got an X and a
light component for each of those grid
points okay good alright so now we're
gonna plot everything lot everything so
here I'm just gonna move this down okay
so I want to do something kind of cool
when I say subplots 2 by 1 by 1 and what
I want to do is and I want to have two
plots I want to have a top plot and a
bottom plot in the top plot I want to
actually visualize what my vector
is doing like in P plain and on the
bottom plot I want to visualize what my
particles are doing as they integrate
through okay so in my first subplot I'm
going to define dy equals my double gyre
Veck of at time 0 with Y initial
condition a eps Omega and there's the
super cool command called quiver have
you heard of quiver yeah so quiver is
awesome if you do if you give it a bunch
of U and V velocities on a grid it will
essentially plot them like in P plain
quiver because you have a quiver of
arrows right it's a bunch of arrows ok
so we're going to use the quiver command
and we're gonna plot why I see the X
component let's see this is gonna be
super long so I'm going to plot the okay
so quiver takes in the X component of Y
I see the X component of the position
then it takes in the Y component of the
position then it takes in the X
component of the vector field then it
takes in the Y component of the vector
field sorry yeah so I called this y
component so I dumped out the vector
field into the Duy object
okay so quiver takes in X component of
the position y component of the position
X component of the velocity y component
of velocity and it draws those velocity
arrows at each of those positions ok but
if I run this I think it's going to be a
little bit weird let's see I have to
change folder ok so it's a little hard
to see that because there's so many
values that I'm plotting right there's
so many of these arrows so what I'm
going to do is I'm only gonna plot every
fourth value I'm gonna say 1 : 4 : and 1
: 4 : end
I'm only gonna plot every fourth arrow
now it looks a lot better okay and I
should probably also do some nice
plotting things I'll say axis 0 to 2 0
to 1 and I'll say draw now okay cool we
have a vector field it looks awesome
right and this for you know 4 times 0
this is exactly the double jire vector
field but as we increase time this thing
is going to start moving left and rights
okay good and now in subplot 2 by 1 by 2
we're going to do our plots of all of
our red particles and I'm going to do
the same thing with axis and draw now ok
good so now this is actually pretty
simple right it took about 10 lines and
now we have this great graphical
templates and as we integrate this set
of particles through this vector field
for each DT we're going to be able to
see how the particles move and what the
local velocity field looks like ok
questions about the plotting techniques
or anything at this point just interrupt
if you have questions please yeah change
any of these signs and the stream
function or be noted in the beeping
yeah I have a minus sign in the V
component but it doesn't matter it's now
the flow is going down instead of going
up but it's yeah it's the same I
couldn't find a good convention for what
the sign is on the stream function and I
haven't derived it myself in a long time
so I'm just using what's in the paper
okay good so that was part 1 part 1 was
initialized a grid of particles we
didn't integrate throughout any vector
field so we just initialized a grid of
particles and we plotted them right so
part 2 now we're going to integrate
these particles through the vector field
okay part 2 compute trajectories ie
integrate okay good so now we've already
defined a DX and a DUI and we have our
grid but now we need to define a DT
unless you so for DT we're gonna say
0.025 again this is my time step for
integration and I'm going to integrate
from time 0 to time Big T equals 15 this
is the duration of integration so we're
gonna integrate from time 0 to 15 in
increments of 0.025 and in every step
we're gonna keep track of what all those
red points are doing and what the vector
field that they're living in looks like
ok good so first part is to actually
integrate this thing let's see so Y in
equals y initial condition for I equals
1 to T divided by DT and what do I do
time equals I times DT so first thing
I'm going to plot my new vector field
because my vector field is changing so
my top plot is going to be changing at
each of these DTS so I'm going to go
back to subplots 2 by 1 by 1 and I'm
basically gonna do this thing again okay
except I'm not going to be running my
double gyre vector field at time zero
and why initial condition anymore I'm
going to be running it at time T and why
initial condition okay right this this
time is changing now so here I'm gonna
say that I'm running this at time equal
to time okay seems pretty reasonable and
the next thing I'm going to do is I
actually need to integrate my particles
so this was just plot the plot vector
field now we're going to integrate
particles and to integrate the particles
I'm going to use my RK 4 single step
runge-kutta integrator that we derived
for the Lorentz system so here I'm going
to just use RK 4 single step on this
double gyre vector field ok so what is
my RK 4 single step taken as input so
what do you need for a runge-kutta
integrator what is it 45 taken as time
as inputs a right-hand side function and
actual conditions and a time step
probably yeah ok so what do we have
ok so Y out equals RK 4 single step and
I have to give it a function of T and Y
which is my double gyre Veck at t and y
with the parameters a eps and omega
locked into place right a Epson Omega
are those three parameters that someone
else defined and I'm just locking them
into place to force this to be a
function of just T and Y and then I also
give it my DT my current time and my
initial conditions Y in so you can look
up these are the four arguments that I
need for RK for single step I need a
right-hand side vector of just T and why
I need a DT my current time and my set
of initial conditions I'm going to
integrate
so I take why in and I get why out okay
that's one time step and at the end of
that time step I'm gonna say that my new
I in is y out for the next time step
right at the end of every time step this
Y out becomes the Y in for the next
integration okay so the last part is to
plot the particles and I'm just going to
copy and paste this part here draw now
yes so usually if you ran this without
draw now since it's computing so many
frames it would wait until the
computation is done and then show you
the last one but with draw now it's
going to update every DT you probably
don't well it might be that if I just
ran the whole script it wouldn't show
you that one it would just start showing
you these yeah yeah I'm not loves weird
I just put draw now's when I can't see
things that I want to see okay so now
what we're plotting are the particle
positions of Y out one what do I want Y
out one :
and y out two : now this is super weird
what's what's the how big is this Y out
and why an object what's the size of
these things how many dimensions do they
have as a race how many of you think
they're one dimensional arrays two
dimensional arrays three dimensional
arrays okay so the 3s have it this is a
three dimensional array right it's got
the X and the y position of all of my
two dimensional grid so this would be
sized to by 81 by 41 so this is a super
bad notation that I'm using but this is
apparently good MATLAB code
is if you have a multi-dimensional array
and you say anytime you say : it
essentially takes every other dimension
of the array and it just stacks as a
really tall column vector so I'm taking
the x and y position I'm taking the
expositions and I'm turning them into a
huge column vector with this notation
and of taking the Y positions and I'm
turning them into a huge column vector
with this notation super confusing until
you get the hang of it like you should
try this out sometime like for example
if I say
Veck equals one's 2x3 okay so I have
this big maybe if you call it
Nats equals ones 2x3 so size of mats is
2x3
but if I say mat of : I get a huge
vector of six ones weird okay but it's
MATLAB so weird is okay and I think
that's it I'm gonna run this let's see
if something interesting happens okay so
we have an integrator and for every DT
of this integrator we plot the vector
field and notice that I'm plotting the
vector field using my initial conditions
because I'm using that regular grid I
started with I'm not using my new points
because I want to know what the vector
field looks like on the whole regular
domain then I take a time step I advance
my points one DT in the future and then
I plot the points I really hope this
runs yes okay good
and what we're seeing is you know every
DT all of the particles being affected
by this time varying vector field the
cool thing is that this is a real
research problem it's a toy problem but
it's a sophisticated enough problem with
chaos and high dimensionality and
relevance to physical systems actually I
have three papers I've already written
using this double dagger vector field
and this toy code that you're about to
get so you can do really really cool
things with this
and actually kind of make advances in
theory using this simple model does they
don't want me to run this one more time
yeah one more time let's do it again
okay so the blue field is oscillating
the left vortex is getting bigger now
the right vortex is getting bigger and
as that happens you see that these
particles are getting kind of mixed up
into these bases and one hypothesis that
you might have is that from the
particles point of view this is a
chaotic vector field meaning if I took
two nearby particles and I ran them
through this thing they might end up
kind of exponentially separated in a
short amount of time
that's what chaos means that's
absolutely true and that's something
that we actually get to explore with
this okay are there questions about what
we've done so far before we do the chaos
part yeah
how's my computer can do this
integration so my computer is just
hauling ass right now trying to
integrate all of these particles and
every time it gets an answer it plots it
then it tries to integrate another set
of particles once it gets an answer it
plots it so this is limited by how fast
my computer is yeah I wanted to pause I
would say pause 0.1 now it's gonna pause
for 0.1 seconds every time you can see
it doing that right it's like tick tick
tick tick tick tick tick so it's got a
built in DT pause but I don't like that
I want to go as fast as possible if I
had a smaller DX like if I actually use
a reasonable DX like what I might do in
a research problem that's not the
reasonable DX then it's going to be a
lot slower not too much slower actually
it's doing a pretty good job in fact I'm
gonna keep it I like this because you
can really start to see these very
interesting patterns that are developing
in the flow so for example let's say
that what's a good example let's say
that this is Oregon and this is
California these are the coasts okay and
I live in California and I'm gonna dump
pollution so what I would do is I would
drive 2 miles north to Oregon and I
would dump my position right here
because it's gonna get carried out into
this Oregon gyre okay and I'm not going
to dump my pollution on the California
side and it turns out that this actually
is a pretty valid model like in Monterey
Bay there is a gyre and there is a line
you can draw in the sand where if you
dump pollution on one side it gets
carried up to the deep ocean and you
don't have to worry about it in the
short term and if you dump it on the
left you're in big trouble ok so the
next part of the analysis I'm going to
show you really starts getting into this
idea about where you would start dumping
your pollution let's see if I can do
this
I am going to jump to a code that is
completely written ok so magically we
have about 50 or 100 new lines of code
here and let's see if I can just bring
this in graphics on is a flag that I
define so if I turn it to one then it
plots things if I don't in it so the
plotting actually slows my computer down
a lot it's like 10 times faster if I
don't plot stuff so sometimes if I want
results I just turn all the graphics off
and tick and talk is to time the code to
see how fast it it runs so I'm just
gonna quickly cut and paste some code
into my code and it's gonna break
everything let's say I define graphics
on equals 1 ok so now I'm doing
something funny so I'm taking [ __ ] I
shouldn't have done this ok I'm gonna go
back to my working code so for every DT
I integrate through this thing right and
I've plotted and I've plotted and I
plotted and at the end of that DT what
I'm gonna do is I'm actually going to
store my trajectory
ok so X trajectory and Y trajectory are
these monster vectors that actually have
the monster arrays that have the
trajectory ok good I run it through it
cranks through will just let go a little
bit longer
so what I'm going to do is for every
single one of my initial particles right
I had this nice regular grid of initial
particles before I started integrating
and I'm going to take a stencil of
particles so I'm going to look at the
particles directly to the left and right
and above and below my particle and I'm
gonna see where did they all go and I'm
going to essentially use those
neighboring particles to approximate the
derivative of where particles go with
respect to X and Y and I'm going to plot
so that is a weird matrix of derivatives
I get this matrix D F D flow map is you
know partial F partial X partial F
partial Y this is the first component
partial F partial X partial F 2 partial
Y so the derivative of the x position
with respect to X the derivative of the
Y position with respect to X position
with respect to Y and so on and so forth
and I'm gonna take the largest eigen
value of this and I'm going to plot it
because that tells me if I have a really
large eigen value at some point that
means that my neighbors went way far
away from me in some direction we don't
know what direction but in some
direction okay let's look at size of X T
just because I'm curious I don't
remember what I did here okay that's
just the X and that's the last the last
point in my trajectory so this means X
at time Big T okay so I'm computing the
finite difference derivative gradient
just like I said I'm going to compute
this finite difference of all of my
final positions with respect to my
initial positions then I'm gonna pull
out the largest eigen value and I'm
going to plot this thing and what I see
here these are these high color values
the bright yellow regions are where the
flow is the most sensitive to the
initial condition so for example right
here if I start a particle right on that
yellow Ridge
then what this is telling me is that
particles to the left and right and
above and below are going to two very
very different places and that makes a
lot of sense in this double gyre right
because I have this separator so if I
started you know left or right of the
separatrix then they're going to very
different places they're on the saddle
point kind of so this is like the time
varying analog kind of a saddle point we
have these particles going to very
different places in time and we just got
this from looking at the particle
trajectories and calculating the
derivatives and the maximum eigen value
so you can go through the code and kind
of figure out what this means and what
this is doing you can also plot it as a
surface if you like right so height here
indicates that you're getting a lot of
separation between neighboring initial
conditions so places where there's a lot
of height you get a lot of separation
from neighboring and show conditions and
so finally what I'm going to do is I'm
going to define let me just run this one
more time so now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to pick an initial grid of
particles in this boring blue region
where my math is telling me that I don't
get a lot of separation so these should
all stay similar to each other they
should stay close to each other and I'm
gonna take another patch that is
straddling one of these funky sensitive
regions in the flow and we're gonna see
that we get very very different behavior
in each case okay so this is I'm going
to run a small patch of particles
through and the particle patch is
defined on this region here so I'm just
gonna like plot this so that was one
patch of particles that I'm running
through they started off in a boring
blue region and notice that he they
started off together as a rectangle they
moved around but basically they ended
together okay so this blob of oil stayed
coherent through this double gyre vector
field right it stayed in one coherent
blob of oil let's do another one so now
I'm going to take a patch of particles
that was sit
square on the middle of one of those
ridges that was very sensitive and you
see that very quickly this thing gets
sheared and stretched so that
essentially that set of initial
particles went to completely different
places there's some all around these
boundaries very very different places so
this would be like the worst well
depends on what you want do you want
your oil to stay in a tight ball of oil
forever or do you want them to get
spread out to everywhere so if you want
your oil spread out everywhere this
would be the best place to drop it but
if you want it to stay in a coherent
blob over Oregon you want to drop it
over here okay so this is you know kind
of the idea of what you can start doing
with vector fields I didn't tell you how
I got that sensitivity map this
sensitivity map here which I already
killed but the the plot where you saw
the yellow curves that were sensitive I
didn't tell you how why that really
makes sense but it does I can tell you
about that offline sometime but the idea
is with a vector field I can integrate
particle trajectories and then I can use
those particle trajectories to do
analysis about where the flow is
sensitive to initial conditions where do
particles go in time are their preferred
places where oil will attract or run
away from are their places if you're
going to dump pollution you should or
shouldn't dump it or if someone's going
to you know detonate a dirty bomb in
Manhattan we would like to know where
the contaminants are going to go in five
minutes ten minutes fifteen minutes and
these are exactly the kinds of analyses
you do you calculate the vector field
with some uncertainty and you would drop
you know a grid of particles and you
would see where they go and you'd
calculate you know where you should put
sensors for chemicals where you should
have evacuation plans depending on which
way the wind is going and things like
that okay I have one minute left that is
everything I wanted to tell you it's
been a pleasure teaching you this
material in this course and I'm really
looking forward to 565 and seeing you
all again so have a great break
and I'll see you all soon Thanks